[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette convention est là principalement
pour objectif de coordonner les
acquisitions foncières des deux
établissements publics engagés tous les
deux sur le même territoire l'un pour
réaliser la ligne 18 et l'autre pour
réaliser les aménagements qui vont
concrétiser le développement sur sur le
plateau dont il était vraiment important
qu'on puisse définir la méthodologie et
puis les modes de détention des terrains
puisque l'objectif de ce grand paris
c'est de pouvoir notamment restituer à
l'établissement public
ceux qui n'auront pas été utilisé pour
réaliser mes 30 ans et les premières
dates sont celles qui a donné le premier
ministre dans sa feuille de route au
mois de février dernier rappelle que
l'objectif de réalisation de la ligne 18
en totalité d'orly jusqu'à versailles
c'est 2030 avec une échéance de 2027
pour la mise en service entre orly et
s'attelait que nous avons proposé c'est
de réaliser une mise en service
anticipée sur la section où la sous
section entre massy palaiseau donc au
niveau de la station du rer jusqu'à
saclay avec un horizon de 2026 et donc
les appels d'offres qui sont en cours
notamment le premier l'autre génie civil
qui est l'un des trois principaux lots
de cette ligne est en cours de
consultation dans cette perspective là
et ce marché devrait pouvoir être signés
tout début de l'année prochaine deux
en 2019 et 2020 vont être effectivement
des années principalement consacrée au
lancement des marchés
il y aura évidemment des travaux mais
des travaux préparatoires qui
s'inscrivent depuis quasiment l'enquète
public et le décret d'utilité publique
de 2017 afin justement de préparer
l'arrivée
l'arrivée des chantiers principaux les
travaux préparatoires c'est quoi c'est
enlever déplacer les réseaux divers et
variés des concessionnaires en dehors de
l'endroit où vous allez avoir par
exemple le gard où un orage annexes en
il y aura un lancement important c'est
ce de marché c'est celui du matériel
roulant
je rappelle que le matériel roulant et n
18 est légèrement différent de celui qui
a été attribué l'an dernier pour les 15
16 et 17 peut donc se dire est ce ce
marché donc l'appel d'offres sera lancé
au printemps après matérialise une de
manière assez concrète le caractère
irréversible de ce projet on n'achète
pas du matériel roulant sinon c'est pas
le projet les autres marchés qui vont
venir il y en a un sur lequel j'insiste
particulièrement parce que c'est celui
qui finalement va va être déterminant
pour le calendrier de 2030 pour la mise
en scène jusqu'à versailles c'est tout
le génie civil
saint-quentin devant le golf national
jusqu'à la gare de versailles
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir signer ce
contrat au premier trimestre 2009 1 2
avec un lancement d'appels d'offres qui
pourraient être lancés fin fin 2020
voilà les principales dates en matière
de calendrier